polenta to the Italians is what mashed
potato is to Britain's a staple
incredibly delicious and really
straightforward to do now season the
water it's a little touch of olive oil
stops it from becoming too sticky
I love polenta it's a cornmeal made from
ground right maize the more course the
longer it takes to cook but you can also
buy instant polenta which is ready in
under 10 minutes and always use this at
home and then we stir now as it cooks
out it naturally thickens you see the
grains becoming almost into one nice
fine pureed polenta to take the polenta
to another level flavor-wise seasoned
with salt and pepper a good knob of
butter and Parmesan record genuine to
the parmesan because blender can be
quite dull I like it quite rich and
creamy delicious now I mix that in nice
smooth shiny glossy planters you can eat
polenta two ways like this is a glorious
fluffy mash or set then griddled which
is what I'm doing
start by oiling a baking tray pour in
your polenta
now get down the fridge and then it's
set
[Music]
next I'm roasting vine tomatoes to
really intensify their favor olive oil
the bottle on the tray and drizzle
extra-virgin olive oil on top nip your
tomatoes with your scissors if you
didn't burst them before the way in the
oven then explode
salt and pepper garlic just squeeze the
juice out the garlic says its martyrs
blister and roast it's going to take on
all this lovely garlic to give the
tomatoes a wonderful sweet-and-sour
flavor a pinch of sugar embalming
vinegar this is a wonderful aged
balsamic vinegar and then sometime don't
pick the time just trim like you're
having a little haircut nice the
smartest only take ten minutes to roast
now the polenta set is ready to griddle
it should just fall out beautiful
blenders are nice garnish for grill
needs it's great when you're planning a
big dinner party the polenta can be done
one or two days before a nice season top
and bottom a nice it's not coating or
fat olive oil and then on to your grill
now this looks very impressive but it's
so easy to do get that grill really nice
and hot make sure you got a fish slice
and your underneath to turn all that
nice sort of marking and char on the
planter gives that really nice flavor
now tomatoes look got these beautiful
vine tomatoes that have been roasted and
all that wonderful flavor
[Music]
I know get your little Tomatoes and just
sit them on top drizzle over any
remaining roasting juices the perfect
addition is a goat skirt ghost cure
gives it that nice sort of salty creamy
taste ghost cheese cream cheese or creme
fraiche will work just as well
drizzle a little touch of that aids a
spurt vinegar and then a little basil to
come way to dive in this dish is
fantastic we entertaining in the morning
set your polenta the night before and
you can have this casual brunch on the
table within minutes fuss free cooking
that looks like a labor of love